Hello, and welcome back to the Rawkode Academy.
I am your host, David Flanagan,
also known as Rawkode.
Today, we're taking a look at an application
called DevStand.
We're gonna find out in just a moment
what that is, but before we talk about
it, we need to introduce its creator and
maintainer.
Welcome, Max. How's things?
Hi, everyone. How are you, David? Yeah. You
know what? I'm doing really well. I haven't
streamed much in the last week because of
speaking at an event in Oslo, and I
had my own conference this week. So I'm
really excited that I get to be back
in my office,
have a stream with you, and, like, a
really cool a really cool project. So thank
you so much for taking the time to
to join me this afternoon.
Well, nice.
Thank you for having me.
Yep.
My name is Max.
I'm a full stack developer, and I've been
a full stack developer for the recent like,
around fifteen years.
And it was just a couple of years
ago when I started working on a project
which is now called DevStand.
But, originally,
the project
came
when
I was working for a client, and the
client asked,
okay. Now your solution
have to be deployed in Kubernetes.
And nobody knew
what was that, how to work on that,
and I had lots of time figuring out
and wrapping my head around it.
And
during working with the Kubernetes,
I realized that it's quite difficult.
I mean, if you need to create a
Dockerfile,
it's usually like a script a bash script
for making a virtual machine, like, in the
like, roughly.
But Kubernetes brings
a whole lot of it's very custom
terminology,
and you have to understand it first and
then trace it back and realize, ah, in
order to do my thing, I have to
do this and that in Kubernetes to make
it work. And I
had a strong belief
that
the whole technology is awesome,
but it's quite difficult, and there must be
a way
to make it simpler for mere application developers.
Because, you know, those developers who spend lots
of their time working on
business logic,
database schema, interfaces,
negotiating features
with their clients, etcetera, and they have no
time and no
wish
to dive deep into that modern Kubernetes
cloud stack.
So DevStand
is a thing for
mere application developer
and
which lowers the barrier towards cloud deployments.
So this this is basically it. Awesome. Well,
thank you for sharing a little bit about
yourself and about the project too. It's it's
always nice to get that extra context and
history when we do these sessions. And I
love what you're saying. You're 100% correct. Like,
the lexicon that we need to understand what's
happening in a Kubernetes cluster is not something
that we have by default. It doesn't map
to to the real world or even things
in the past. You know, it could be
that maybe we called it an application and
people would understand Kubernetes a bit easier, but
we don't. We see pods, replicas, deployments, config
maps. Like, these are not terms that people
are familiar with by default. So
I
really love it. And I I
I think it's a really powerful thing when
we could take some of these things with
Kubernetes and make them easier to understand through
visualizations and other tools. So, yeah, I'm really
excited for for today's demo.
Okay. So now I'm going to share my
screen
and
start my Let's do it. My presentation.
Uh-huh. Your screen is now live with our
audience. I can see your slides. Please feel
free to take that away in your own
time.
Well, that's great. So
after several demos to fellow developers,
I realized that some of them think of
DevStand as a low code tool for cloud
infrastructure.
I personally believe that it's more about
platform as a service atop any Kubernetes cluster,
but you can see that both of these
names can be applied to the solution.
I wanna start with the
most well known
solution for branding developers'
code and shifting it to the cloud,
platform as a service. And every platform as
a service has two basic promises.
The first one is that it has to
be easy for developers,
and it's worth noting that
popular platforms as a service is they usually
deeply rooted, and they originate from developer community,
not infrastructure communities.
And they have to speak to developers in
their lexicon,
and they they didn't even sell
support for a specific programming language.
They usually sell support for a specific framework,
and they
gradually build
trust between them and developers. So developers
know they can rely on expertise of the
platform as a service to to jump and
to deploy their application.
The second core promise is
that infrastructure
is managed by the provider.
But in terms of platform as a services,
this infrastructure is not about networks,
gigabits,
gigahertz.
It's about
managed services,
like a database or
domain specific API
or some kind of
CICD automation.
And you
might think, what is the industry
response to that PaaS weeds part? Many
people think that Kubernetes is because bundle everything
in a container image,
throw it into Kubernetes, and Kubernetes is smart
enough to realize how to how to run
it.
But
well, actually, Kubernetes fails
to fulfill both of these core promises,
what I believe. The first of all, it's
not easy for developers because, as I've just
told, it forces you to
utilize
Kubernetes'
own terminology.
And it's weird, and it it doesn't speak
familiar obstructions for developers. And one of the
most beautiful features of Kubernetes,
that declarative configuration,
often ends up as a wall of YAML,
which is huge, and it's blindly copy pasted
from one repository to another.
And this wall of YAML that they still
do not speak in the language developers can
understand.
In
to continue comparison with the past, there are
no managed services in vanilla Kubernetes.
Even so called managed Kubernetes offered by a
variety of
cloud providers
are just bare bones.
And you have to hire professional DevOps people
to get anything specific and usable from your
cluster.
But be besides the hiring need, which would
better to avoid,
every custom Kubernetes cluster is unique.
There is no golden standard, like a packaged
Kubernetes packed with add ons,
and it means that
there is no
straightforward
path
from code to Kubernetes because every Kubernetes is
a little bit different.
And this is what DevStand is trying to
achieve.
I have three next slides in in steps
explaining how to come from that wall of
YAML
to DevStand. So imagine
a usual
or decent application. Like, you have a web
application, maybe a background worker,
a database,
maybe file storage,
or Redis cache,
and
all of that information of how that should
be deployed in Kubernetes
buried somewhere
between the lines of these huge YAML files.
But what if we can spot
reusable
templates,
reusable portions
within this
huge YAML files,
rub them in templates or functions,
and call these functions in a way developers
can understand.
And each of these function has to have
a set of parameters
to actually produce
this huge list of
Kubernetes
manifest. For example, in this code,
we have web application,
which accepts an image and port,
an optional domain. And for
image and port, by default, it creates deployment
and service.
And if
a domain is provided, it also creates an
ingress.
What I want to pinpoint here is that
just that
one line of that
code
is actually what developers
care,
is that PaaS
lexicon or that PaaS experience.
Developers just want to know, okay. That cluster
is capable of running web apps on a
specific domain.
Or think about a database.
A developer
who is not responsible for managing databases
just wants a host name, a username, password,
and the name of the database to use
it, and that's basically it.
But if you think of a
decent configuration in Kubernetes for a Postgres or
a MySQL,
it consists of lots of line of code,
and they make no sense for a mere
developer. So okay. First, the the output of
that slide is we have these named functions.
Then
it can allow us to create a single
file
and with a compact syntax where
you can list all of your microservices,
your app, your background worker database,
and
reference
these
function calls
within
within that file. So for example, in that
example, you have web application,
background worker for email delivery, and Postgres database.
For example,
a worker,
it's it's obvious that it has to work
from the very same image, so it's referenced
the very same image from
my app component,
and it shares all the environment configuration.
What's also interesting is that
in
any programming language to reference values, we use
variables,
And that code is written in JSON. It's
like JSON interpreter,
JSON with macros.
And
we can
observe
dependencies between these components just by looking at
which variables
are referenced.
And
you can wrap anything
within
building block within the template. Think of it
as a
managed service of a cloud provider. For example,
when you run integration tests,
you are fine to have a stateless Postgres
container
or
in internal Kubernetes cluster, your custom corporate cluster,
you have a a decent
claim into a database operator.
Or in public cloud, that Postgres can be
a claim for Azure
database or
AWS
managed database. So
it's quite
easy to swap things
underneath.
But for a developer,
we have the very same interface. It's just
a database.
It within
the template, it can be
a microservice developed by other team, or it
can be an off the shelf solution, like,
for example, a little WordPress install.
You can give your content managers. They they
use it to to write text, write code
writing, and you just consume that as an
API for your content. So
there are plenty of ways to encapsulate
your very specific things within these templates.
But in the end of the day, you
have a very short
file,
which is, by the way, backwards compatible with
all that all of YAML, and all the
syntax
within the that file
makes total sense for developers.
Why do I talk a lot about these
functions and interfaces?
The idea is that strictly typed code could
be visualized,
and this is actually the primary and the
core feature of DevStand.
It's an editor built into Visual Studio Code
to be as close to developers as possible,
and it allows visually
compose your solution architecture of these little building
blocks and interconnect
them
to each other.
And I have a
demo for it.
On our canvas,
we have add component button, and we see
a list of all the available components that
a developer
can utilize as a building block.
Oh, sorry.
Okay.
So we select web application,
give it a name.
Come on.
It
happens all the time.
So
once we have a new square put on
our canvas,
we have to fill
the these two
parameters of that web app function, the image
and port,
and we have a web app.
And at that
exact step, after a few clicks, we're already
capable of deploying
that image running with a web server, running
on that port to Kubernetes.
But let's look what's more possible here.
Let's create a database.
We also give a short
name for it and configure environment
for our application
with a drag and drop.
That was it.
So you just
referenced
and explicitly
declared
a dependency
between your web application and the database.
And since it's visual, it's really easy to
wrap your head around all the solution infrastructure.
Let's have a worker.
It has to run the very same image
as the primary application,
but with a different command
and also sharing
the very same
environment.
So
I think it's pretty simple
and easy to understand.
Like, what do you think?
Very impressed.
There's a few things here. It's like, I
haven't seen,
you know, JSON used in this way, but
it's it's really it's really clever because you
get a lot of composability
and flexibility by adopting JSON over just regular
YAML. Like you said, the ability
to define types, to create functions,
to have parameterization,
like all of these things
would have been cool on its own. But
the fact that you have this extension that
we can run and the tooling that we
use every day to work with our code
and give us drag and drop and visualization
to connect all those dots.
It's it's just too cool. That's that, like,
it's very
maybe we've got a wow for a from
Redeemna in the chat there. So there we
go.
You're impressing people.
But, yeah, like, you know, I I know
a lot of the time,
you know, we say, oh, we love the
command line and oh, yeah, we'll just break
code all day.
But these UI tools
are very convenient. They speed up our development
process. And you've always got the escape hatch
if you need to go through something else,
but there's a reason tools like from a
networking policy point of view, like the Cilium
editor and Hubble are so important because they
allow us to take complex things. Like you
said, the great wall of YAML and
that's not grokable, it's not understandable especially across
disparate files, many files, thousands of lines. You
have no idea
what the output of that is until you
have something like DevStand.
So I can't wait to see more. Exactly.
So
we have just tried to move our Kubernetes
closer to
PaaS,
but
I think DevStand is also beneficial in comparison
to PaaS.
Let's compare them in in terms of easiness
for developer
and control.
And I think DevStand is
a good balance
between low level and high level tooling
because
in Kubernetes, you can configure anything, but it
usually requires lots of low level plumbing,
and it results in bad developer experience and
difficulties to understand what you're actually doing.
In comparison to PaaS, it has great developer
experience,
but
you cannot usually escape that walled garden of
your cloud provider. And
once your solution
receives a decent traffic,
it can become
really, really expensive to continue working on
the same path.
But what's most important that
from time to time,
any developer
faces a situation when
they have to deviate somehow
from that golden path or so called paved
road
that the
provider
of the path had in mind while developing
that
platform.
The sometimes you just have
to tweak something
that it's not possible within a platform.
But with DevStand, you still retain control of
the underlying
configuration.
You can
pipe
the output of the DevStand
to customize
and do anything extra,
or you can write your own transformation
at in JSON at at top of that
breadboard file.
I
think
it it it there's something in it. Before
I talked about the primarily about the private
cloud, thinking of it's enterprise
or inner
inner source
solution
for developers
working within a company
brought by DevOps team also working in the
very same company for their fellow developers, for
their colleagues.
And
but I believe there has to be a
cloud solution
as well.
Think of
a
SaaS service when you can just create an
account, receive a freemium or trial,
can give credentials to your AWS
or Azure or DigitalOcean
account, the credentials.
And then that
SaaS
can create a new Kubernetes
cluster
and make it act as a path.
And once you need, for example, a database,
you can have a managed database
from a cloud provider like this serious thing
in the very same simple way as that
just little square on your
canvas.
And
what I see
for the future of DevStand is that
a couple of
products.
The first one is the open source edition
of DevStand for
in house development. It can improve
velocity
of internal developers. And since it's open source
and
and no fees required,
it can boost adoption,
and we can receive a lot of valuable
feedback from those early adopters.
But it also has to have something living
in the cloud that is just plain simple
that a mere developer can stumble upon that.
And once that developer lands in a company,
he can just say, well, I know a
thing
that helps save me lots of time,
and you can usually
utilize the very same thing within
a company infrastructure.
Like,
for example, you know,
GitLab is doing the same.
You can create your account at GitLab,
or you can have a self hosted GitLab.
It and it spreads
the GitLab across the world regardless if it's
paid
and cloud or it's unpaid
and
self hosted.
What
do you think is
what would you like to see more? More
of an open source thing? And do you
believe that SaaS
is really important, like, in in that product
mix?
Both.
I'll I'll be really partial. Like, you know,
I always love to see open source software
because,
you know, the more it allows you to
build a a sense of community and with
and, you know, onboarding new contributors,
helping them, allowing them to shift the direction
of the project, having a a common voice
that tries to push something forward and improve
adoption, I think, is really important.
But I also understand
that,
you know, open source isn't gonna pay our
bills. We all know that. Exactly. You know,
I I I think companies that go down
this Azure,
you know, they can be wildly successful. You
know, we see a lot of examples like
this. Grafana is the most ubiquitous dashboarding tool
in the world for observability
and monitoring and platform engineering,
but they have a hosted SaaS version because
sometimes people just need convenience. Maybe they need
enterprise features like, you know, SSO against SAML
or whatever.
So,
yeah. And FoxDB do the same. They have
their open source database and it's completely open
source.
But if you don't wanna roast host it
yourself or you want this couple of extra
features, then go with this as well.
I think as a model, we see it
work well. The last example I'll give is
Pulumi does this too. Everything Pulumi does is
open source.
But, you know, if you don't want to
manage your state files, you give me a
little bit of money and they do it
for you. So, yeah, I think the strategy
is is tried and proven to work. And
I love that it allows us to keep
things free,
allow developers to experiment, and help shape the
vision for the project.
Mhmm.
That's good. That makes total sense.
And for the demo, it's basically it.
I have
a video demo
explaining
and showing how that works a little bit
deeper.
But
maybe before diving
further,
you can have some questions or we have
some questions in the comments.
Just people saying that things sound interesting. There's
a comment there from Alina.
With,
oh, wow. That's interesting too.
So and for them that also said at
the start, but I forgot to show the
comment is that, yeah, for new people, Kubernetes
does sound scary. Although that is getting better.
But it's also getting better through improvements to
Kubernetes itself and new custom resources, but also
by tooling like this, which I think is
really cool.
You know, what I also noticed after several
demos,
there were no people saying
meh about
that solution. There were clearly two camps.
The first camp were people
quite enthusiastic
about that solution.
They told something like, yeah. That totally makes
sense. It would save time. It's it's good.
It's good. Can continue working on that.
But there were completely opposite
idea.
Like,
I don't know why you just developed that.
Like, Kubernetes
Kubernetes is sophisticated for a reason.
Like, it it just has to be
complicated
because it's a serious thing.
And
No. I don't agree with that whatsoever.
I think Kubernetes being complicated
is because the project is still young and
we haven't found the right abstractions
yet. And we still need to build these
abstractions. And I see DevStand as a tool
that can allow us to build these abstractions,
you know, by leveraging JSON on it. You
know, we allow we allow people to have
repositories where they contain these abstractions like a
web app or like a worker or like
a queue or like a
post grads database. Like, this is what Helm
does, but Helm
probably made a few mistakes. I don't know
many people that like Helm and the reason
is why.
Well, it uses Go template and syntax and
not every consumer of Kubernetes even uses Go
or writes and Go. So they have this
barrier to entry where they're looking at something
that just doesn't make sense. I mean, I
remember still looking at helm templates for the
first time and going at like, what is
this range dot syntax? Why is dot context?
What's a context? And it's like, have to
understand scoping and this is like, what's what's
wrong with mustache and handlebar syntax? Like And
and don't forget the right amount of offsets
in the beginning of line. Oh, yeah. And
having to end on things and and and
and how those work and new lines breaking
and empty object.
It's really tough. Right? And I'm not saying
JSON it is
better, but it but it is. It's more
familiar at least because it's JSON with some
extra tweaks on top of it. So
yeah.
So long way to say, I I disagree
with the people that made that comment. Kubernetes
does not need to be complex. That's what
people say that wanna protect their smarts. But
really,
we need to make Kubernetes available to to
everyone. We we need to make it simpler
to the right abstractions.
And it's only over time we can actually
understand what those abstractions should be.
Yep. We got a couple more comments there.
So, Pradumna's Oh, sure. In love the product.
We've got Kumaraju saying no image files and
YAML's. Great.
And we've got one from Russell's
in I
assume most business devs that have been responsible
for supporting and for dependencies, DB's, Kubernetes, etcetera.
Probably want to have it managed as a
service ops can be hard. So plus one
for SaaS. I know the comments are a
little bit off the screen there, but I
need to fix that later.
Well, that's great to hear such feedback.
I encourage
the listeners to go to the website DevStand.app.
And at the very bottom of the main
page, there is a
little
form when when you
where you can leave your email address and
receive
updates.
I haven't posted anything yet, but I believe
I would have some big updates
in the fourth in the forthcoming months.
So stay tuned. And even if you want
to
have a a deeper talk about the the
technology or you have an idea of how
to
fit DevStand into your very specific case,
also just
leave your email. I would
reply you back and we can talk. Or
you can directly send me an email at
max@DevStand.app.
Alright. Awesome.
I guess I've got a question then before
we dive straight in to the demo. Mhmm.
So
for anyone who's currently using
JSON to deploy their application, will that work
by default with DevStand? Will I be able
to visualize that?
Or to is there something slightly different to
the way
that things work?
I'm not sure on
on the studio question. Right? But we'll see.
I have a a micro service just now
that has a conflict map and a deployment.
And I I I I deploy it with
JSON. So I'm using JSON as a compiler,
and I'm typing it through to KubeControl apply,
but I don't have any DevStand.
Is there a way for me to visualize
that with DevStand?
Not. No. Okay. Because, yep, you have to
have these functions
quite strictly structured.
You have to provide JSON JSON
schema
for your configuration
parameters.
And so
your
so the plugin can understand
or read
your code and extract that information
from your code.
Because as I told, nothing is hardwired
to the plugin itself. Plugin is just a
visual visualization
of a very specific
way of coding this JSON and functions.
Okay. Alright. Let's see it in action then.
Let's have some fun. Good.
In order to
avoid any hiccups and to save time, this
is a recorded video.
So let's
so we have a very specific directory.
It doesn't have to, but for the demo
purposes, I have the directory dot DevStand.
And right clicking
on that directory in Visual Studio Code and
selecting Scaffold breadboard directory
will create
a new breadboard file
and immediately open it.
Nice.
I got add component,
web application.
Just set the
image,
the port.
And, yep, before piping into Kubernetes,
we can just select view manifests,
and a new editor opens in a separate
tab. When you have all the output
of that breadboard file,
you have all your ports
for the for the deployment
and specification
for the service itself.
We can add
ingress
over here.
And
just checking that the local host domain just
properly
is traced to the local host.
It's good because the demo was recorded on
the local
computer.
And among the manifests, we now have our
new ingress,
which references
the host name to our service
and port.
Okay.
So and once we are ready to deploy,
just click pipe to kubectl,
and a terminal opens up
with just that pipe command.
Okay.
We have created deployment ingress and service, and
this is this is a very
a few words about that demo application. This
is file manager that just uploads files. That's
a a
very basic feature to to show.
So
what if we can update our
domain right there within our breadboard?
And once we apply
to Kubernetes that breadboard again, we see that
nothing is unchanged except the ingress,
And the previous link
doesn't work now.
But once we visit a new address,
it works.
Alright.
So You happy to take questions as we
go? Sure.
So I'm curious now. Like,
is there the means with DevStand?
Like, okay. Let me try and set some
context first.
You know, I don't just deploy to one
cluster. It's likely I'll have some sort of
dev cluster at a production cluster. So for
the ingress, it may be that I wanna
pull that value externally or change it based
on where I'm deploying to.
Is there any way of pulling external
configuration? Sure. Well, I
mean, at the very
moment,
that's not developed yet. But, sure,
as you can see later, you can use
variables
Right. Okay.
Within your JSON, and you can have, like,
a top level configuration.
Like, this is my production
domain
top level domain. This is my development top
level domain. And, sure,
it's possible to use that
suffixes within
your JSON files.
Alright. Well, I'll I'll keep watching.
So just to have a look at it,
yep, we have our
application deployed,
and, well, we even can
see that the the container is actually running.
Let's
create
more components
and add a storage.
For s three compatible storage,
let's use Minio.
And in the very same fashion,
we create
extra configuration
for that storage.
And the
the application,
oh, while it's being deployed,
the that file manager application, that that demo
application is written in in PHP with Laravel
framework.
And Laravel framework has a built in feature,
the so called file system drivers. So
access
when your
application
wants to access a file system, it can
be either local file system or s three
file system or
FTP file system.
In order to configure our Laravel to use
that s three storage, we have to set
a file system driver equals to s three.
And now we have to
I can I can just
yep?
And, again,
since the
the software is very early,
it
should like, in in the way it it
is now, it it's not ready for production
because in ideal world, it would be something
like there is a secret associated
with that storage component.
So you can just drop the whole secret
into your application, and it will be mounted
as a file
or end file or
put inside your environment variables.
But for that demo purposes,
I think it's quite clear to to understand
how it works and
where is the value of of that solution.
So
once we have that
the whole configuration
and deploying.
So storage
wasn't changed because nothing has changed and just
the configuration of the web application was
updated.
And now for the demo time,
uploading
real files to that
file manager.
Yep. And our files appear in s three.
Nice.
So in the very same fashion, it will
work with databases
and any other
microservices
or domain specific APIs or any other thing
that works with standard protocols.
I have the
last piece of demo
trying to show
what are the relations between
the presentation and the file itself. So right
now, I'm going to open in Visual Studio
Code the same file
two times.
So on the upper side of the
Visual Studio Code,
you have the breadboard editor, that visual editor,
and underneath it, you can see that
plain text file,
which is actually
the source
for the visual visualization.
Here you see that you have my app,
which extends that web app function
and configuration.
You can update
either
for example, in your company,
you do not call web apps like web
apps. You develop APIs, and you call them
web service.
You can do that. And you as you
can see, once you update your text file,
the visual
designer
reflects all the changes immediately.
Nice.
You can update your
exact values, for example,
tag or report.
You can even rename it right into the
code editor,
or you can rename it in visual editor.
And since this is just
Visual Studio Code,
you just can hit your keyboard shortcut for
undoing or redoing actions. It it will automatically
redraw
both
plain text file and the visual editor.
But what's inside this
web app function?
This is actually a code
in JSON. I
won't say it's, like, very straightforward,
but this is the way how JSON and
code is written.
And the very last thing
oh, yeah. You
do not have to use
Visual Studio Code
to actually utilize DevStand, for example, within your
CICD pipeline.
You can have the just binary
and DevStand manifests and pass through that breadboard
file,
and you receive
your YAML. And you can
process that YAML further within your pipeline,
for example, with a customize at something at
top,
like your custom domain or
annotations,
labels.
And the last thing, and I think it's
really, really important,
since the underlying file is just a plain
text file,
it's ready for Git.
And within Visual Studio Code,
you can easily spot
what has been changed.
Yep. We just added
ingress.
It just feels natural
that
it's
so straightforward.
And
that's what that was it.
Nice. Awesome.
It's a cool project.
Let me pop this back over to there
we go.
Yeah. If anyone watching has any questions about
DevStand, now is a good time to drop
them into the comments, and we'll ask them
before we wrap up for today. So if
you wanna know more, you've got ideas for
new features,
feel free. Speak now.
Alright. So,
yeah, we've got to thank you for the
demo. There we go.
Yeah. So I I like this.
So we can take
the JSON on it. We build our own
abstractions.
We commit them to get
That is
what
losing my words today completely. What I like
here is that we can have people that
want to write JSON and bother with abstractions
go and do that. But you've created this
other area for just consumers. Like you said,
the Latterfield Developers out there, the people working
with Ruby on Rails, the people that are
building databases.
Whatever.
Like they have the option though to just
consume the abstractions made by other people
and a very visual way to connect the
dots with the variables that they need.
And the JSON is is there. They can
commit it to get they could push it
somewhere. CI can take over. But
it's a tool that enables people
to do things that they couldn't previously do.
And I think that's really important. We need
to make this easier for people to deploy
to Kubernetes.
And it's just a cherry on the top
that it runs in Versus Code. Like, I
love that. Like, it's not another tool. It's
not an electron application. It's not a web
application. I'm already in my editor, and I
just think that was a great decision that
you made there.
I mean, don't get me wrong. Have no
idea how you write Versus Code extension, and
I have no idea how you make it
actually, like, a drag and drop of a
board with little dots and connectors.
But yeah. Very cool.
You must
like,
I wanna know just
how like, were you a Versus code or
Node. Js developer before? Had you done graphics?
Like, I I I'd love to know more.
Well,
a Visual Studio Code
has
a notion of
editors.
And one of a way to create a
new editor within Visual Studio Code is to
make a WebView,
and the WebView has to
follow certain protocol
for intercommunicating
between Visual Studio Code
and your JavaScript
running within your
web view.
So the whole editor is basically a
web page.
Code is written in Svelte framework.
I picked that one because because it's has
the the least amount of RAM to be
used for
drawing dynamic
HTML.
So and there are two parts of the
extension.
The first one is that
web view thing,
and another part is the
actual code,
which
written in in TypeScript,
scans file system,
find files, update a specific file.
If an interesting thing is that
I can show you.
Is that
the
code
the extension actually treats
the
JSON file as code. And when you update
something,
it actually update that very specific line and
that very specific portion of code that you
reference. For example, if I have
this
as
my
comment.
For example,
a DevOps person or a developer left a
comment
for
for their colleague.
Once you update
something,
like,
We have your comment
preserved.
The I mean,
it
would be much easier
to just dump the whole configuration
and override the whole file. Yeah.
Yeah.
Or something like that.
Although, do I have a feature request? Like,
can we get those comments as little yellow
posters on the the breadboard?
I haven't thought of that. That that's a
that's quite a smart
thing.
It would be even
even simpler.
Yeah. And if we look at a comment
on, let's say, 17 for the image, then
that could be, like, a little annotation on
that property on the in the UI as
well. Like, you could take you could take
comments of first class citizen here. That would
be very, very cool.
Yeah.
Something like
just
this
cute
the other one. Yeah. Yeah. And then we
get a That's a great idea.
Alright.
We do have a question for Russell in
the chat. Russell is asking,
are there any plans on providing best practice
templates? So like, are you gonna release a
obstruction library with like API
or web app or
I don't know, Kafka deployment.
Like, you know what we see with Artifact
Hub and Helm? Do you see DevStand having
a space on Artifact Hub where people push
these obstructions
for reuse and sharing?
Sure.
Right now,
when you when
you scaffold
and you
breadboard,
it automatically
fetches
the
default templates.
Think
of them as provided by the the the
creator of DevStand.
You can throw them away and replace them
with yours, but there should be something, a
default to start with.
I think of
having templates
for usual stuff like web app or databases,
but it should also be
integrated with a popular Kubernetes operator.
For example, there is a Kubernetes operator for
Postgres,
or you have a Rook for many databases
or Redis operator.
And they have their very specific CRDs,
which you can you you you have to
follow that notation,
that syntax for claiming
a new Redis instance, for example.
And I think
that has to be provided out of the
box for
newcomers as well.
I see that that open source version of
DevStand will come with something like
a wizard
step by step. For example,
the first step, hi, your DevOps person.
DevStand provides
out of the box integrations
with these
20 popular Kubernetes operators,
a menu operator,
Postgres, Redis. You just click them,
selecting those operators that
existing
DevOps team already implemented
within their Kubernetes cluster,
and then just return, okay. You just have
to have these several functions to utilize.
A good question about distribution.
I had NPM
as a source of inspiration for it.
So,
basically,
it fetches
from GitHub,
either
GitLab
or
Bitbucket
just any Git repository.
It just fetch
these
repositories
and store them in this
JSON or PKG
directory.
It means that you can also
for example,
I'll just open.
So
that's code
for the
for the functions.
Mhmm.
And that's the schema for the properties that
you can
configure within within your
within the designer.
And if you have
that,
I mean, that specific
repository is public, so once you fetch it,
it's fetched as a
tar or a zip file and extracted.
But if it's a private repository,
it would be just git cloned
with your SSH key,
so it's safe to distribute
these libsonnet
these JSON functions or these DevStand templates
within your private Git repository.
Okay. We have a question kind of related
there from who
was asking, can we provide custom keys
and values? So I'm assuming he's asking how
do we
extend
that schema. So maybe we could take a
look at one of those functions and just
show a little bit of the JSON that
makes that work. Okay.
For example, this is for the web app.
Yeah. What if we wanted to maybe it's
already done, but what about requests for CPU
and memory? Is that part of your spec?
Well, right now, well, it is not. I
I
still have
that
on my on my list. Yeah.
But, yeah, right right right now,
it's
you either have to create your own function,
or
since this is just
this is just JSON, you
can
and I honestly, I can't remember how I
did that while prototyping,
but either you have to be able to
write something
over here.
It's like
cube
deployment.
You know, somewhere over here, you have this
Yeah.
Well, I don't know how this works in
JSON.
Are these structures closed?
Like, can you just add a b c
and the value of one underneath line 14?
What would happen if you do that to
the UI?
If you just do a b c pull
on one. That's that's for,
for example,
how
low
Yeah.
It is possible.
Hello,
world. Alright. Nice. Yeah. So those structures are
open. So you can start to you could
start to add your own. But you you
you yep. But it wouldn't be compiled to
anything. Right? That Well, you can you can
still edit them. Yeah. Okay.
Nice. Very cool.
Alright. Let me pop this back over.
Alright. Well, I don't think we have I
I remember how to do that. Oh, yeah.
Sure.
It has
to be
plus.
And here you have all your overrides over
here.
And for a developer,
it can be easy as okay.
That portion of code, this is what I'm
responsible for,
and the rest of the gibberish is that
what my DevOps people do.
Have often classified the work that I do
as as gibberish, so I appreciate that.
Yep. That that that
should definitely work,
that plus thing,
because this is a native feature of JSON.
Nice. It's a good question.
Alright. Well, I don't think we have any
more questions. So I'll just say thank you
for taking some time today to to sit
down with me and to show everybody DevStand.
I'll finish with the
the easiest question.
But, like, what's coming next then? What are
you working on right now?
Well,
right now, I'm
working
mostly on the commercial side of the project.
I'm trying to
rise
some
investments so I can
continue
working
on that project full time
because
it requires a a significant amount of time
to make it work to fix box and
to to push it forward because
I already have lots of features in my
wish list, but I just didn't have enough
time to implement them.
So
and as for the very first iteration,
I see it
something like works
with,
for example, DigitalOcean.
Like, every
like, most of developers, they have their account
in DigitalOcean, so it would be quite straightforward
to just
integrate that solution with
DigitalOcean managed Kubernetes to to
and to see how it works there.
And
maybe something
that SaaS version can be
obvious first step when you have just restrictions
for, okay, you can host either web apps
or background workers and manage databases from DigitalOcean
and just these three options. And to
I did and just
go through all the obstacles
required to to release
that first
working versions.
And then once I can
make it slick with just one single provider,
then I can bring all the features back
to the open source version.
But I definitely
will continue working on the open source version
because I truly believe
that Kubernetes
has to be simple.
Awesome.
Thank you again for your time.
I'll finish with, you know if you had
asked me six months ago what I thought
of JSON, I would have said it was
dead. And I I I genuinely believe that
DevStand may be the project that brings it
back to life. So I'm gonna wish you
the best of luck. I can't wait to
see what's next. So please get in touch
with the new version,
and I'll see you again next time. Have
your last words?
The well, thank you very much for having
me. I really appreciate your feedback,
and
kudos to our listeners for being engaged and
asking for questions.
There are still a lot on the tape
on the table,
and
thank you very much for
your time.
And
thank you for an opportunity to share
what I've been working on
for the recent, like, year and a half.
That that project is really important for me,
and I really wish it
finally takes off.
Alright. Well, we're all rooting for you. We'll
all contribute at help, and we'll see you
again soon. So thank you again. Have a
great day.
Thank very much. Have a good time.
Bye all.
Thank you for watching Rawkode Live.